if you stay through the end credits of
2016's Deadpool you probably heard the
lead characters say this the sequel
we're gonna have cable no he wasn't
talking about upgrading his TV package
cable is actually a longtime member of
the x-men family of Marvel Comics not to
mention a constant foil for Deadpool but
with all that said why hasn't cable got
in his own solo film here's a look at
why Hollywood won't give cable a movie
named recognition
never say never but it's kind of hard to
imagine many people going out to see a
movie about the Cable Guy and there's
some historical precedent to back this
up well maybe I shouldn't come at all
sure Joe outside of comics fans few
people have even heard of him and if
they have they probably don't know much
more than its name which isn't really
much to go on even if you didn't know
who Iron Man and the Hulk were you could
probably guess who they are and what
they do cable that lack of name
recognition is a huge hurdle especially
given the multitude of other issues
facing the character simple name
complicated origins Caples comics
backstory sounds like an outtake from
drunk history I want to be called snorky
ready to get confused strap in cable is
the son of Cyclops and a woman named
Madeleine Pryor who is actually a
demonic clone of Jean Grey he suffers
from a technic Pyrus which slowly
replaced his body parts with liquid
metal and organic steel threatening to
kill him his only hope is a
time-traveling being made of pure energy
named sisterís Connie who appeared to
Cyclops in a vision into the young
Nathan 2,000 years into the future
believing him to be the savior destined
to deliver them from apocalypse because
apocalypse is behind the techno virus
apocalypse yes right teamed up with the
tooth fairy
lots of time-traveling shenanigans
ensued and eventually he landed in the
present-day Marvel Universe older than
his parents and that's just a backstory
that led up to his first appearance in
1990 meanwhile Peter Parker was bitten
by a spider
fashion don't
cable is something of a joke in certain
circles held up as an example of comic
books convoluted plots and the excesses
of character design in the 1990s famed
comic artist Alex Ross broke down
everything that's not appealing about
the character when he once said cable
look like they just threw up everything
on the character the scars thing going
on with his eye the arm and what's with
all the guns powerfully problematic
let's talk about cables powers like his
mother
he's telekinetic able to manipulate
matter with his mind and his cybernetic
eye and arm give him enhanced vision and
super strength also he can travel
through time he's built like a redwood
tree and loves gigantic nerve style guns
in other words he's way too powerful and
seems like he was designed by a
committee of ten year old boys which
isn't far from wrong you created x-force
and so what is this drawing this is the
spike man and what's this writing look
at the camera on top of your head that
will support the wrongdoings of ever so
Rob have you had any formal art training
no reruns one big question for adapting
cable to big screen
what the heck do you do with him his big
thing is time traveling to change the
past but x-men covered that already with
Days of Future past and as archenemy
apocalypse yeah they did that one
already - in 2016 with x-men apocalypse
if the filmmakers wanted to use cable
they had two golden opportunities to
include him but they chose not to for
reasons that are probably becoming clear
super sidekick it's perfect the cable is
set to appear in the forthcoming
Deadpool sequel because Deadpool
satirical poked fun at the genre style
is a match made in heaven
for cables convoluted in over serious
backstory it's a big house it's funny
that I only ever see two of you it's
almost like the studio couldn't afford
another x-man
in fact there's a long rich history in
the comics exploring the comedy goal to
be mine from the pairing but now that
he's set to debut his Deadpool sidekick
it seems pretty unlikely that he'll
actually graduate to his own movie but
hey stranger things have happened
major risk small reward here's the
bottom line when a character needs so
much reimagining to be viable on screen
it's a major problem look no further
than fan favorite Galactus for proof in
the comics he's a purple suit of giant
who eats planets for breakfast lunch and
dinner but the filmmakers behind 2007's
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
opted to portray Galactus as a giant
fart cloud in space comic fans hated it
and film fans hated it too because
really a cloud even parallax thinks
that's stupid
at least that was a fart cloud with a
face Fox faces the same issue with cable
if they remain true to what may the
character popular in the comics film
fans will likely just be confused and if
they don't comic fans will be
disappointed
it's a lose-lose scenario which means
that for now the big screen will
continue to suffer from an ongoing cable
outage thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know if you think
cable should get his own movie